hey guys uh welcome to my channel and uh
i guess i'm hoping to do this
recurringly but i wanna you know have
this as a place to talk about systems
design i'm currently studying it a lot
myself and i feel like i've learned a
lot in the process
but uh yeah let me give a quick
introduction about myself and and why
i'm doing this so
um i'm an incoming software engineer at
google sorry you got click baited um
and i literally have nothing that really
qualifies me to actually talk about
systems design i'm not a senior engineer
or anything but um
yeah you know i've been uh learning it
and uh watching a bunch of these youtube
videos and um you know there's a few
reasons now that i want to make this
channel um one is that i'm a narcissist
and i like the sound of my own voice but
two and probably a lot more importantly
is i find that a lot of the existing
resources especially youtube videos are
for people who really oversimplify
things right like they'll build this
huge system they'll be like okay i'm
gonna build a facebook messenger and
then they'll talk about um all the
design choices that you have to make and
go into basically zero details on why
they choose one technology versus
another and that always really
frustrates me because i would like to
see a deeper dive because i feel like
you know you're kind of just a sham if
you
just regurgitate some youtube video and
you know if your interviewer is like
any like any amount of smart or
skeptical he'll just ask you why you
made the choices you did and you're not
going to be able to answer
and so you know i think part of that is
you know doing more of a fundamental
dive onto how some of these technologies
actually work before you just go into
you know full-scale system design
example problems and that's what i'm
planning to do so you know without
further ado i'm going to talk about
database design and
yeah hopefully it helps you guys out
all right so let's talk about database
design
just to start from the beginning for
those of you who are really new to this
stuff and keep in mind i have time
stamps if you want to skip around what
actually is a database well for starters
if you and your friend or well since
we're programmers we don't have friends
but if you and another person want to
access the same piece of data from an
application or you just want to access
it in the future such that it's not
actually on your local device again
you're going to need a database
generally clients will interact with a
web server which will then go ahead and
store all data that needs to be
persisted or kept in the long run on a
database
the objectives of the database are
pretty simple obviously if you're a big
company and you hold a lot of data all
you really want to do is have fast reads
fast rights and durable data what that
means is if the power goes out on the
machine holding the database that the
data doesn't get lost
so how do we do that well we would use a
hard drive
hard drives are basically
pieces of hardware that go ahead and
hold data for a durable amount of time
as you can see they basically work by
having that little penis arm thingy go
and spin around
the metal disk which goes at either 5400
or 7200 rotations per minute generally
speaking
and the big thing to note here is that
with hard drives you always want to aim
for sequential operations what that
means is that it speeds things up quite
a bit to be accessing data that's much
closer on the disk to one another so
having to jump around all over the disk
means the penis thingy is going to have
to do even more searching and it's going
to take forever to actually find and
write the data that you want
okay so let's talk about what a naive
database implementation might be think
of it basically as an array of tuples so
every single time you want to read you
have to search through the array and
every single time you want to update you
also have to search through the array
for what it is that you want to update
writes are still in constant time which
is good but for our purposes this
clearly isn't good enough
as you can see if you want to update
something like
id3 over here you literally have to go
find it and then change it in place a
slightly better implementation is an
append only log what that means is that
you actually overwrite things by just
writing an additional entry in the log
this way you can actually benefit more
from sequential rights so i'll go ahead
and show how that would happen
as you can see i've literally just added
another row to the log and that way i
know that searching from the bottom to
the top of the log i can actually get
the correct data
something even better would be to use a
hash map
if you remember from your algorithms
class you basically use a hashing
function to map a given key to a certain
place in memory and the hashing function
should distribute those keys out in such
a way that you're able to get constant
time accesses and also
that just means that you can read and
write really easily however this doesn't
really work well the second that you
can't fit your entire hashmap in memory
it's really bad to put a hashmap on disk
by virtue of what we discussed before
which is that random reads and random
writes on disk are really bad because
the mechanical arm has to go around and
spin all the time and it means that it's
going to actually take longer to edit
that data so as you can see while hash
maps might be really good when there's a
small data set
the second you're dealing with a ton of
data which is mostly what we're worried
about here they become pretty infeasible
so let's talk about how we can make
reading faster because we just spoke
about writing basically writing you can
solve by literally just using an append
only log
however reading is kind of the bigger
issue because a lot of applications are
super read heavy so how do we actually
make reads faster we use something
called indexes which basically keep
extra pieces of metadata on every single
write in order to help
track
which values of certain rows are the
same and that way you can basically
query them really easily so looking at
the table in the bottom right here if i
want all the rows with customer id 2 for
example i could really quickly find them
without having to do a linear time scan
of the entire data set
so obviously the pro of this is faster
reads but if you put an index on every
column such that you can efficiently
query the data using every single column
what's going to end up happening is that
writes are going to take a really long
time
okay so let's go over three types of
index implementations and
these are basically the fundamental
different types that you can use and by
going over them we'll have a good idea
of which databases to use for certain
applications and why
first of all hash indexes like i
mentioned before this mainly relies on a
hash map which means that all of your
keys basically need to be able to fit in
memory the entire point of the hash
index is that for the field that you're
indexing on you take the key and then
you map the offset on disk as the value
in the hash map so that way i can
literally do an of one constant time
access in ram and then i would be able
to easily scan to the disk there are a
few problems with this one of which i
already mentioned is that if the keys
don't fit in memory you're screwed out
of luck because hash maps just work
really poorly on disk and additionally
and perhaps even more importantly if you
want to do a range query which means you
want to quickly find all of the keys
with a given range of values
they're going to be scattered all around
disk and that's going to be very
inefficient because then you have to
keep doing more random accesses
okay now let's move into another one
that is a little bit more feasible for
actual databases these are called ss
tables and lsm trees so the way that
this type of thing works is on rights
you would first write to an in-memory
buffer so this in-memory buffer means
that on ram you would have a
self-balancing tree like a red black
tree or an avl tree i don't know who the
might remember that but apparently
some people actually know how those work
so anyway that would be called the mem
table when the tree becomes too large
you take all the contents of it which
should be automatically sorted by virtue
of using a tree traversal
and you would write them to something
called an ss table file and that ss
table file would be held on disk
in the event that the database crashes
obviously whatever's in memory is going
to be lost so we keep a second log
called a right ahead log
expressing all of the changes that we
have in the tree and that way
if the machine crashes you can easily
restore that tree
furthermore i should note that once you
write the tree to disk you reset the
tree to nothing again and you start
writing keys in there
so as you can see writing a key would
literally just be adding it to the lsm
tree
okay continuing so i've mentioned that
you write lsm trees two ss tables on
disk so here's what ss tables might look
like as you can see the keys are
actually sorted and right next to them
are their values so using nba players
here i have 0 for russell westbrook 7
for carmelo anthony 9 for dwyane wade
and so on and we might have multiple of
these ss table files like i mentioned
because every single time that that lsm
tree gets too big you're writing it to
an ss table
another thing to note is that you might
actually have duplicate keys between the
two
since everything is an append only
operation if you want to overwrite a key
it might just go into a newer ss table
file
so by virtue of overwriting the key 33
we can see that the value of it changes
from jabar to pippin
okay but the issue is by virtue of
having all of these duplicate keys or
potentially wasting a ton of storage if
you're updating the values in your
database a lot you might be using a ton
of space that you could actually just
get rid of if you were to somehow
compress these ss tables so that's
exactly what we're going to do
as you can see we're now turning it into
a compacted ss table and what does that
mean it means that all of the duplicate
keys are going to have their updated
value and additionally all of the other
keys are also going to be in the
compacted ss table
how do we merge these together well it's
actually really efficient if you
remember from merge sort you basically
start at the top of each ss table and
then start taking the keys in order so i
would start with westbrook and iverson
and say the zero for westbrook is
smaller than three for iverson so that's
going to be first in the compacted table
then we would say the 3 for iverson is
smaller than the 7 for anthony so that's
going to be next 5 is smaller than 7 and
so that's a linear time operation
between those two tables to easily
compress them
and so that's a process that often gets
run in the background to optimize in
storage space
so as we can see that's merged in linear
time and in the case of the duplicate
key such as 23 33 and 34 we're always
going to take the more recent value
because that's the correct one so we're
always going to give file two here
precedence over file one
okay continuing further we've discussed
how we might write to access tables in
lsm trees but now let's discuss how to
read
so firstly when you're looking for a key
you would query the mem table we would
literally just do a binary tree
traversal and look for the key in there
which is o of log n
secondly we would look at each ss table
in order from newest to oldest looking
for the key the issue with this is that
fundamentally you might go through ss
tables until you have none left and if
there are a lot of them and the key is
not in any of them you've wasted a ton
of time
there's an optimization called bloom
filters that kind of help this out so in
practice it's not actually so brutal if
the key doesn't exist but even still
from a theoretical perspective it's bad
on reads
another optimization to that is the fact
that all of these ss tables are sorted
so what we can actually do is keep a
sparse in-memory hash table for each ss
table so that we can quickly search them
so for example in the ss table below you
see i have a bunch of names of people
and their corresponding ages so what
i'll do is i'll keep a small hash table
so that i know it can fit in memory of
basically the keys
that are sparse but in order and their
memory addresses so say i have alice bob
and charlie and i know all of their
memory addresses and i want to be able
to find andy i know that andy's key is
between alice and bob because the ss
table is sorted so i'd actually start at
the memory address of alice and start
the memory address of bob and run a
binary search what that means is that i
would basically be splitting the
the disk chunk between them in parts of
two and that way i could do a login
search on a sorted array if you don't
remember binary search you can
definitely look it up and it's really
easy to understand
okay so to summarize ss tables and lsm
trees the pro about them is that writes
are really fast there's an in-memory
buffer and writes to memory are always
significantly faster than disk because
memory is just much closer to the cpu
additionally they're very good for range
queries so if you want a range of
if you want to get all of the values for
a range of keys you could really easily
do that because ranges of keys are
stored together in the ss table since
they're sorted
the bad part is that reads are
relatively slow you might have to go
through a ton of ss tables and do a lot
of searching and that could potentially
be pretty devastating
additionally the fact that you're
emerging resources in the background
might actually use some database
resources and make things a little bit
slower
okay moving on from ss tables which is
one implementation of an index now we
have another one called a b tree the
entire point of eb tree which is
decently simple is to model your data
such that it is a tree on disk so let's
say i have a bunch of names and i want
to be able to find the corresponding age
like i did before
as you can see i want to be able to keep
all of my data in order and then have
pointers down the tree to show where the
actual data is so as you can see in the
top level here the root page i would
have a reference between all keys that
go from a to e out of reference from all
keys that go from e to p
and all keys that go from p to z
so let's say i want to find the name
thomas
i would first take the ref from p to z
because i know that thomas is between
the letter p and z
moving on to the next page i would now
say okay i'm going to take the ref
between t and z because thomas is
between t and z
finally i would ultimately go to the
page where values are actually stored
which tends to be about three or four
levels down to have many many terabytes
of storage assuming the the tree pages
are large enough and as you can see i
can easily get my value all this can be
done in logarithmic time
so to actually put this into words to
read you literally just traverse through
the tree and find the value to update
you traverse through the tree find the
value and then update it and then
finally to write this gets a little bit
more complicated because if there is
space in a given block where a key
should go then you can just put it there
and if a given block of the b tree so
like one of those layers of it basically
is out of space and there's no room to
add the key and its corresponding value
then you actually have to split that
page in two and update the parent page
to reference both of them um the thing
is that process can actually um you know
if it if splitting the pages and
updating the parents if the server
crashes
you're actually going to have to be able
to restore that so what you can do is
use a right ahead log similar to with
lsm trees where you write all of your
changes down tentatively before you make
them so that in the event of a crash you
can go and restore that
okay b trees what are they good for well
reads are very fast because you have a
logarithmic time complexity and you're
only going down around three or four
levels
another good thing is that it's really
good for range queries as all the keys
that are
you know next to one another in the
actual range are physically next to one
another on the drive
the biggest con is that rights are slow
you're writing directly to the disk as
opposed to an in-memory buffer like on
an lsm tree
okay so let's get to a conclusion
obviously in a system it's really
important to be able to justify the
choices that you're making in a systems
design interview if you just named a
database engine and said i'm going to
use this
you'll obviously get a look and they'll
say well why would you do that so now
you can actually justify this hash
indexes are great but they're really
only useful for small data sets so maybe
something like a redis database where
everything's already in memory could
work well
an ss table and an lsm tree is really
good for when you have to write a lot
and write quickly but it's not great for
reading because you risk having to go
through a bunch of ss tables finally b
trees are really good for reading but a
little bit slower than ss tables and lsm
trees for writing because you're not
writing to an in-memory buffer
all right i hope that was
a deep enough dive without being too
overwhelming if you want more
information on this subject i definitely
recommend reading data driven intensive
applications by martin klepman but uh
yeah hopefully you guys can now make
more informed explanations about how
databases work and these two types of
database designs that are pretty crucial
for determining the performance of both
read and write throughput